esta vuelta a españa- da un giro brusco
a partir de esta tercera etapa abandona
territorio neerlandés para entrar ya en
suelo español este domingo vamos a
analizar el desarrollo de la ronda
española también las opciones de los
ciclistas latinoamericanos en la
competencia para ello contamos con
nuestro compañero especializado en
ciclismo lionel pusher y lionel
bienvenido llevamos ya tres etapas de
vuelta pero hemos visto cosas
interesantes que nos puedes contar de lo
visto hasta ahora y que podemos esperar
de las primeras etapas en españa
concretamente en un territorio tan
ciclista como es el país vasco
buenas noches después de estas tres
primeras etapas hemos visto que había
cosas que estaban que estábamos
esperando por ejemplo era la el
liderazgo del jumbo bismack que es el el
equipo más fuerte y son los favoritos
para esta esta vuelta a españa con clima
sólo gris y desde la primera etapa que
fue un crono por equipos y haga ganaron
esta primera etapa y están nivelando la
clasificación general que eso no es una
sorpresa tampoco es una sorpresa que la
la segunda y tercera etapa se haga nada
por velocistas porque eran muy indianas
estas etapas planas y no hubo sorpresa
ganar o ganar ganó dos veces sant benet
a esas etapas al sprint y eso era como
lo que se esperaba lo que va a ser más
interesante es a partir del martes como
tú decías este cambio total va con la la
vuelta españa que de verdad llega a
españa y al país vasco
ahí no va a haber ninguna etapa plana va
a haber un media montaña una montaña
durante toda la semana que viene y lugar
se espera que va a haber más movimiento
y también quizás más más acción para los
amantes del ciclismo esperamos estabas
hablando de sandro variante se espera
que por ejemplo el martes o el miércoles
estas etapas le puede convenir a
al veterano español para su última
vuelta a españa en su última temporada
de este monstruo del ciclismo hoy vamos
a ver si es capaz de ganar una de esas
dos etapas el martes on the line alcohol
es una opción también sería el francés
campeón del mundo actual giuliana
mckinney y la para las etapas siguientes
ya empezamos a partir del jueves la
montaña a la alta montaña y es lo que se
esperaba
quizás más acción en estas etapas y en
esas etapas siguientes hasta el fin de
semana el próximo fin de semana si
lionel se podría decir que empieza
claramente la vuelta a españa- las
etapas con más peso luego de este
periplo por el territorio neerlandés
vamos a centrarnos ahora en los
ciclistas latinoamericanos y si hablamos
de latinoamérica en esta vuelta hay que
hablar desde luego de richard cara paz
que va a correr con esta su última gran
vuelta en el equipo y neos como llega a
richard cada paz a esta vuelta a españa
y será capaz de ganar o de enfrentarse a
primos robles que también llega con
ciertas dudas después del tour
para realizar cada paso y un misterio
que no se sabe bien en qué en cómo llega
está esta vuelta a españa y sobre todo
por esta historia de contratos de cambio
de equipos que fue oficializado el
viernes el mismo día que empezó la
carrera su cambio de equipo para el año
que viene va a ser el de líneas y el año
que viene él va a correr para el
education trust el ies que es otro
equipo siempre hay una duda de común
mentalmente y también cómo se puede
comportar el equipo cuando un corredor
para estar en esos cambios porque si se
supone que mentalmente estaba pues
metido no tan concentrado sobre sobre su
preparación pero sabemos que para la
derecha alcalá para la vuelta a españa
es quizás la carrera que más te conviene
con el giro de italia que ganó a el año
anterior
pues para revisar si hay una oportunidad
pero todo depende de lo gris el aurich
es el ciclista más fuerte en el papel es
el porque acabo de ganar tres veces esa
vuelta a las tres últimas vueltas españa
dallas ganó bridge entonces el favorito
claro para este año la duda es que
rubrique se lesionó durante el pool de
francia sede después de una caída y
anunció su participación esta vuelta a
españa a hacer muchas ferias entonces
hay una duda si es capaz o no pero
glitch de estar a su verdadero nivel o
si va de nuevo a fallar como fue el caso
en el tour de francia entonces de y para
carpas como para dar un design muchas
dudas el otro favorito sería gay en ley
y lo estará adrián o que ganó este año
el giro de italia y qué
intenta ser el doblete que siempre es
algo muy difícil si por el
tema que nadie lo lo ha hecho desde el
dato contaron dos misiones y desde luego
hay dudas también con jilín no ha hecho
gran cosa después de ganar el giro de
italia que no es poco' desde luego vamos
a abrir el foco al resto de ciclistas
latinoamericanos podríamos decir
prácticamente colombianos que esperamos
de ellos que podemos esperar
para la red de los latinos como tú dices
y eso solamente colombianos y
creo que podemos esperar más bien etapas
y quizás un pollo que sería un punto
milagroso para miguel ángel lópez pero
más bien etapas que sea conserje o
hijita por ejemplo qué que es corredor
del bora
el problema para invitar es que va como
también gregario de henley para del
hostal ya no innova como líder de su
equipo antes siempre es un poquito
complicado para salir y ganar etapas o
figurar en la general cuando es es así
para miguel ángel lópez también hay
incertidumbres porque no sabemos bien en
qué estado está porque hubo
un inicio de escándalo por un posible
una posible pues si la investigación de
dopaje que al final no salió nada
y miguel ángel lópez si está pero yo
pienso que para él es más bien de buscar
etapas y etapas de montaña como el gozo
del ser y como lo ha hecho en el pasado
sí desde luego es un gran escalador y
estamos seguros de que intentará ganar
una etapa porque no es un hombre para la
general a priori muchas gracias lionel
por atendernos esta noche y por
mostrarnos todo lo que sea